The war in Ukraine has drastically
raised the alert level for NATO's forces
operating in Eastern Europe.
CNN's Jim Sciutto
got an exclusive
look at how the alliance is training
for the possibility
of being attacked by the Russians.
Dizzying speed.
The fighter
jets zoom
low over the NATO's task force again
and again and again.
These are Polish and German Air Force
jets, but they're playing the role
of Russian aircraft
on attack,
part of air
defense exercises
in what sailors and commanders
say is an increasingly tense environment
on NATO's Eastern Front.
Flying, sailing, readying
for any and all combat scenarios.
These exercises are taking place
in the Baltic Sea
within striking
distance of the Russian enclave
of Kaliningrad.
And it's no accident
that NATO's pilots are flying MiG 29
and Sukhoi 24 aircraft,
just like the Russians fly
its German frigate
Mecklenburgh for Permission
is the flagship of NATO's
very high readiness
task force designation.
The task force commanding
officer says they take seriously.
We are training exercising right now,
but when it's required,
we can relate to every mission,
from maritime security operations
to deterrence
to defend the alliance
whenever this is required
in a very short moment.
The task force is now approaching
Russian territory, Kaliningrad.
And so we're practicing
heightened awareness
that means greater awareness
of everything
from cyber attacks to close observation
or even harassment by Russian aircraft
and warships.
Yankee
raising awareness of Russian forces
is high
right in the middle
of the simulated attack.
Officers on deck report Russian aircraft.
Actual
Russian Sukhoi
fighter jets approaching fast.
Sailors scan the horizon
for sight of them.
They're 50 nautical miles away,
then 20 miles before they turn away.
I'm also,
like I said a bit later,
to Russian warships
approach
coming within
just five miles of the task force.
This force
like the alliance, is international
with ships from the German,
Portuguese,
Spanish, Polish,
Danish and French navies.
I climb down the side of the Mecklenburg
for a fast
boat ride to the Portuguese frigate
Bartolomeo Diaz.
They are members of
Portuguese
elite Special Forces
drill for an attack by small boats.
Their guns trained on the horizon,
watching and waiting.
Helicopters
patrol the waters day and night
These are exercises, but soldiers
and sailors make clear
they are training and readying
for the real thing.
We have to be capable to switch
every hour from an anti-submarine mission
to an end to surface mission
to a passenger transport
deployment of Special Forces.
So
every day is different.
The war in Ukraine looms large here
This task force
now sails
with twice as many ships
and sailors as before the invasion.
And as the task force
commander told me,
they are NATO's
first line of defense
against any new acts
of Russian aggression.
We ended our trip in Estonia.
And I'll tell you, Wolf,
when you go to the Eastern,
facing NATO's allies such as Estonia
and I met the prime minister
while I was there, I kind of colors.
They speak in even starker terms
than the western side of the alliance.
They see Russia as a continuing threat.
In effect,
they don't put anything past Putin.
They're nervous
that he might attack the alliance
and they're preparing for it.
Very disturbing indeed.
Excellent reporting.
Jim Sciutto, thank you very, very much.